it's the food it's the culture it's the
way that it's the mountains it's to see
to love French style and French class
the way they socialize
Oh
in the morning I wasn't expecting
chocolate first thing in the morning
it's just not healthy not Church Tish
humanism
brilliant
this is Lucy's versus versus they're not
weird
they're not weird but it's weird to wear
them all the time now right now I have
so I didn't have any
when I first came to France I got one
and now government it's a bit weird
written in the common
we can't of arrived
a new position on ouya he evangelist
from anteversion taxes perfectly rooks
watson also measure
University of course we are disappointed
we will continue to find one another
amusing eccentric interesting admirable
follow your soul surely follow
just look at the millions of French
people significant UK and the millions
of British people visit France hundreds
of thousands of students to go each way
the relationship would be perfectly fine
we've got a little wrinkle it's annoying
it's not what we would have wanted but
the relationship will be excellent
[Music]
you
you